Welcome to our project
Google Developers Hackademy,
where Spanish-speaking experts
from Latin America
will show you some
of our tools,
developer products,
APIs and new tricks.
This course is divided
into five parts
We invite you to watch it
and learn along.
Here we go.
Hi. Welcome back to the
HTML5 web development
with Google Drive
introduction course.
I'm Cesar Anton Dorantes,
Google Developer Expert
for the Google Drive platform.
In the previous lesson
we learned to connect
your Google Charts charts
with Spreadsheets data.
In this lesson we'll see
the following themes:
Creating a new project
on Google Cloud Console.
Activating G+ API.
Registering an API.
G+ Login button.
And Adding the G+ Login button.
You ready? Here we go!
CREATING A NEW PROJECT
ON GOOGLE CLOUD CONSOLE
Time to register our app
to the Google Cloud Console.
This is very important
since you need
a client identifier
so Google lets you
access the platform.
You need to access
Google Cloud Console first
from cloud.google.
com/console#/project.
Once in this onscreen,
select Create Project.
A new window will open
in which to register
the name and ID you want
for your project.
Though later on you'll be able
to change the project's name,
you need to come up with
an ID you want for it,
because you won't be able
to change it later on.
ACTIVATING G+ API
That's it! Your new project
is now registered,
and onscreen you can see
the ID you chose
and the project number
it was assigned to it.
Time to activate Google+ API
so our app can use
the Login button.
We click on APIs
and authentication to see
the list of Google's APIs.
Now we see a long list
with all APIs available
for developers.
I invite you
to explore it later,
just click on its name to see
the methods it has to offer.
For now let's focus
only on Google+ API.
We can find it
below on the list.
Remember the APIs
are listed alphabetically
but a list with the active ones
is shown first.
Once we find Google+ API,
we click on the "OFF" button
to change its status
and activate the API.
Once it's active,
you'll see it is brought
to the upper part of the list,
that way we can always see
which APIs are active
for our project quickly.
REGISTERING AN APP
It's time to register our app
for this project.
Google Cloud Console lets us
keep our apps separated
for every different project.
This will turn out to be useful
for you as a Google developer.
Let's click on the tab
"Registered apps."
On this window we can see
the apps we already registered
and add some new ones.
Let's click on the
"Register app" button.
Now we can see the
new app registration display.
You just need to give the name
you want to register
for this app in particular
and what platform
it's designed for.
In this case we'll use
the by-default option,
which is Web App.
Once we've given a name
for the app,
let's click on "Register."
This will lead us
to a new window
with our app's properties.
You can also change its name
here later on
if you want to.
For now, we'll click
where it says
"OAuth 2.0 client ID."
Here we can see the client ID
for our app.
Keep it at hand, you'll need it
for the code in a moment.
G+ LOGIN BUTTON
The necessary JavaScript
for the G+ Login button logic
will always be the same
for all our projects,
therefore we'll save
two separate files,
which we will name G+login.js
and G+loginhandle.js.
The best part is you'll be able
to recycle them
for future projects.
Quite practical, right?
This simple code corresponds
to the G+login.js file,
which will hide the button
in case the user
has already signed in,
and it is also in charge
of reporting to him
if a problem has happened
when signing in.
This JavaScript function
corresponds
to the G+loginhandle.js file.
It'll make sure
the JavaScript button
loads asynchronously
and therefore minimize
the loading time in our app.
ADDING THE G+ LOGIN BUTTON
To add the G+ Login button
to your app,
we first need to import
the code we saved
in the G+login.js file,
by declaring its route
to the head tags
of our HTML5 code,
just as shown onscreen.
Declare the route
to g+login-handle.js,
right after the body tag.
This will make sure
the script is asynchronously
executed in the browser.
Copy this code
where you wish the button
to show in your app. You'll
notice one of the parameters
is called "data-clientid."
It's important to emphasize
the "data-scope" parameter,
which lets us use this button
to request access
to other services
in future applications.
That's it, our app will now show
a G+ starting button
when someone enters your app
without his account active
or if the app has no
authorized access
to this app in particular.
This will turn out to be very
useful when you build apps
requiring access
to user information.
I invite you to watch
this lesson again,
this time pausing it
to follow the steps
and copying the code
that is shown.
As a comparison, you can see
an already built example
entering to:
This will be it for now.
See you next time,
where will do a review
of the previous lessons.
I say goodbye for now
and remember:
keep on programming!